Il vous apprend la vigilance ; quand il faut parler vite ou peu,
car on vous coupera toujours la parole.
Ça vous apprend l'importance de la communication,
à savoir poser les questions d'une façon à avoir les réponses que vous voulez,
et dire non de la bonne manière pour préserver la paix.
Mais la plus importante leçon que j'ai apprise étant petite
était l'importance d'être à la table.
Quand on a cassé la lampe de ma mère, je devais être là, lorsqu'elle essayait
de trouver le comment et le qui, car il fallait que je me défende,
car si vous ne le faites pas, le doigt sera pointé vers vous,
et en un rien de temps, vous êtes puni.
Je ne parle pas par expérience, bien sûr.
Quand j'avais 15 ans en 2005, j'ai terminé le lycée et déménagé
de Canada -- Saskatoon --
à Zaouïa, la ville natale de mes parents, en Libye,
une ville très traditionnelle.
Voyez-vous, je n'étais jamais allée en Libye en dehors des vacances,
et pour une fille de 7 ans, c'était magique.
Il y avait des glaces, des sorties à la plage
et des proches très enthousiastes.
Il s'est avéré que ce n'est pas la même chose
pour une jeune fille de 15 ans.
Très vite, j'ai fait connaissance avec l'aspect culturel de la religion.
Les mots « haram » -- religieusement interdit --
et « aib » -- culturellement inapproprié --
avaient été négligemment interchangés,
comme s'ils signifiaient la même chose et avaient les mêmes conséquences.
Et je me suis trouvée à mener débat après débat avec des camarades de classe,
des collègues, des professeurs, des amis et même avec des proches,
j'ai commencé à douter de mes propres règles et aspirations.
Même avec les bases que mes parents m'ont inculquées,
Je me suis trouvée à douter du rôle des femmes dans ma religion.
A la faculté Murabit des affaires internationales,
on n'y va pas de main morte dans le débat,
et la première règle est de faire de la recherche, ce que j'ai fait,
et j'ai été surprise de la facilité avec laquelle
j'ai trouvé que des femmes de ma religion étaient des meneuses,
des innovatrices, de forte personnalité --
sur les plans politiques, économiques et même militaires.
Khadija a financé l'Islam
à ses débuts.
Nous ne serions pas là, sans elle.
Alors, pourquoi n'apprenons-nous rien d'elle ?
Pourquoi ne sait-on rien de ces femmes ?
Pourquoi sont-elles reléguées à des positions précédant
les enseignements de notre foi ?
Et pourquoi, si nous sommes égaux devant Dieu,
nous ne le serons pas aux yeux de l'homme ?
Pour moi, tout cela est dû aux leçons que j'ai apprises dans mon enfance.
Le décideur, la personne qui a le contrôle du message,
qui est assis à la table,
et malheureusement, dans chaque groupe de croyance,
il n'y a pas de femmes.
Les institutions religieuses sont dominées par les hommes
et dirigées par un leadership masculin,
et ils mettent en place des politiques à leur image,
jusqu'à ce que nous arrivions à changer tout le système,
on ne peut pas raisonnablement s'attendre
à une pleine participation économique et politique des femmes,
Nos fondations sont brisées.
En fait ma mère dit :
« On ne peut pas bâtir une maison solide sur de mauvaises fondations. »
En 2011, la révolution libyenne a éclaté, et ma famille était sur la ligne de front.
Des choses incroyables se passent pendant la guerre,
un quasi-changement culturel, dans un laps de temps très court.
Et c'était la première fois que je sentais que, non seulement
j'avais le droit de m'impliquer, mais que j'y étais encouragée.
C'était exigé.
Les autres femmes et moi avions une place à la table.
Nous n'étions pas là pour être les yeux ou les oreilles de quelqu'un.
Nous faisions partie des décideurs.
Nous nous échangions des informations. Nous étions cruciales.
Je voulais et espérais que ce changement soit permanent.
Il s'avère que cela n'est pas des plus aisés.
Il n'a fallu que quelques semaines avant que les femmes avec qui j'avais travaillé
ne reprennent leurs rôles initiaux,
dont la majorité mises à la porte avec les remerciements
des décideurs religieux et politiques,
dont la plupart citaient des Écritures saintes pour leur défense.
C'est comme ça qu'ils gagnent le soutien du peuple pour leurs opinions.
Au début, j'étais axée sur l'émancipation économique et politique des femmes.
Je pensais que cela mènerait à un changement culturel et social.
Il s'est avéré que c'était un petit changement.
J'ai décidé de contre-attaquer en utilisant leur défense,
et j'ai commencé également à citer et mentionner des Écritures islamiques.
En 2012 et 2013, mon organisation a mené la plus grande
et la plus vaste campagne en Libye.
Nous sommes entrés dans les maisons, les écoles, les universités
et même les mosquées.
Nous avons discuté avec 50 000 personnes,
et avec des centaines de milliers d'autres par des panneaux et des annonces télé,
des clips radio et des affiches.
Vous vous demandez sûrement
comment une organisation des droits de la femme
a su faire ça dans une communauté qui, au début,
s'opposait à notre simple existence.
J'ai utilisé les Écritures.
J'ai utilisé des versets du Coran et les paroles du Prophète,
des Hadiths, qu'il a dit, comme par exemple,
« Le meilleur d'entre vous est celui qui est le meilleur avec sa famille. »
« Ne laisse pas ton frère opprimer quelqu'un. »
Pour la première fois, les sermons du vendredi donné par les imams locaux
promouvaient les droits des femmes.
Ils évoquaient des sujets tabous comme la violence domestique.
Des politiques ont été modifiées.
Dans certaines communautés, nous avons dû aller plus loin
en disant : « La Déclaration Universelle des Droits de l'Homme,
que vous avez refusée car elle n'a pas été écrite par des érudits religieux,
eh bien, les mêmes principes existent dans notre Livre saint. »
Vraiment, les Nations Unies, nous ont simplement copiés.
En changeant le message, on a pu donner
une allternative au récit qui a promu les droits des femmes en Libye.
et c'est une chose qui a été maintenant répliquée au niveau international,
et je ne prétends pas que c'est facile -- croyez-moi, ça ne l'est pas.
Les libéraux diront que vous utilisez la religion
et vous traiteront de mauvais conservateur.
Les conservateurs vous traiteront de tous les noms d'oiseaux.
J'ai eu des remarques du, « Tes parents doivent avoir bien honte de toi ».
-- faux : ils sont mes plus grands fans --
au, « Tu n'iras pas jusqu'à ton prochain anniversaire » --
encore faux, car je l'ai fêté.
Et je suis toujours convaincue
que les droits des femmes et la religion ne s'excluent pas mutuellement.
Mais il faut qu'on s'assoit à la table.
Il faut qu'on arrête de renoncer à notre position, car en se taisant,
on permet à la persécution et à l'abus des femmes au monde de continuer.
En disant qu'on va lutter pour les droits des femmes
et contre l'extrémisme des bombes et de la guerre,
on a totalement paralysé les communautés locales qui doivent régler ces questions
pour continuer de se développer.
Ce n'est pas facile de lutter contre un message religieux déformé.
Vous aurez votre part d'insultes, de moqueries et de menaces.
Mais on doit le faire.
Nous n'avons pas d'autre options que de réclamer le message des droits de l'homme,
les principes de notre foi,
ce n'est pas pour nous, ni pour les femmes de vos familles,
ni pour les femmes ici présentes,
ni même pour les femmes là, dehors,
mais pour les sociétés qui vont être transformées
avec la participation des femmes.
Et le seul moyen d'y parvenir,
notre seule option,
est de s'asseoir et de rester à la table.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)